hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video ihr wisst gar nicht was im vorfeld
für eine planung weil das ganze so
aufzusetzen das über aufnehmen kann und
darf jetzt deshalb auch ein bisschen
später ist ziemlich einfach cool
vielleicht habt ihr mit bekommen
vielleicht auch nähte es gibt so eine
challenge die gerade im kommen ist und
diese change ist die tri not to sing and
dance challenge relativ selbsterklärend
der name aber man denkt sich jetzt okay
das ist voll einfach und schafft doch
sowieso jeder sich zusammenzureißen aber
ihr habt keine ahnung wie catchy manche
lieder sein können ihr kennt das
bestimmt so ein neuer lief kommt und
jeder mitsingen möglich bei dieser
challenge tour logischerweise jetzt
allein zu hause ist und so was dann wird
man nicht mitsingen wahrscheinlich
werden dass einige schon aber was sie
meinen
man darf nicht mal im kopf mit bing und
david tritt aber ich finde keine aufgabe
so schwierig ist werde auch nicht nehmen
die schweinezüchter finde ich persönlich
ganz nett mal so als abwechslung zu den
ganzen kram not to love ride to crash
ist cool also ich bin gespannt wie es
wird der laptop da unten also nicht
wundern dass immer mehr unter druck
das geht noch das lied geht noch bei mir
also habe ich ja nicht so oft gehört
dass ich darin kräften hätte aber es ist
schon fertig kommt überhaupt nicht mehr
klar vor dem meine schwester des
gefühlten jahr lang auf klavier gespielt
hat
okay ist und wird im aufnahmemodus
manchmal ist man noch mehr dazu geneigt
irgendwie
[Musik]
lasst euch mal nur darauf ein wird
wirklich nicht mit im kopf bin schon
wieder voll dabei
aber ich will mich nicht bei mir weil
ich hab mich bringen kann
[Musik]
ein bisschen schon wüssten
erkennen
[Musik]
das merke ich ein bisschen vom musici
muss ich sagen dass roger popp in der
haft immer voll steuerpolitik noch
weiter gegangen der community gibt und
sie durch ihre hilfen gemerkt dass ich
mehrere auf dem rad auf dem anderen
folgt ja hier das für zwischendurch
seite falls ihr euch denkt der macht
schon wieder so reaction video oder
irgendwie so eine challenge ich habe
jede menge videos geplant die anders
sein werden weiß die muss ich aber
eigentlich alle mit jemand anders
aufnehmen und morgen kommt mein bruder
zu mir für zwei nächte und dann kommt
auch irgendwann wieder luca wieder aus
berlin das heißt ich hab dann auf jeden
fall wieder die möglichkeit andere
videos zu machen sage ich mal
als reaktion von challenges und so aber
ich finde das echt gesagt neues also
dass jetzt gerade gerichts musste
egal
noch warten
wer action sport manche wieder nerven
mich so etwas möchte ich von oder mit
[Musik]
jonas
sind mir zu viele lieder
[Musik]
so richtig nach diesem weg wenn man
lachen gibt sich die fan kann weil ich
nach diesem lied richtig hätte das
nämlich damals gehört als es rauskam und
ich musste das haben und damals hat man
sich noch für die lieder per bluetooth
schickt dann war ich irgendwie in so
einem ferienlager oder sowas und haben
wirklich alle anderen kippt oder
jugendlichen die dort waren gefragt ob
wir dieses lied haben und ob sich
schicken können und dann hatte ich
irgendwann jemanden gefunden der tasche
und dann hab ich das liegt glaube ich 30
mal pro tag gehört irgendwie eine woche
lang oder so zuversichtlich ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen ich fand es echt
lustig muss ich sagen dass ich ein
bisschen wenig geredet weil ich halt
beschäftigen die musik zu hören
falls ihr euch gefallen das gern mal
eine leiter mit wir uns dann beim
nächsten video wieder und bis dahin kühl